the Super Bowls most valuable player is
Julian Edelman who caught ten passes
last night for the Patriots he joins us
from Atlanta good morning and
congratulations it's so great to talk to
you it's good to be here I appreciate
you guys having me you were on fire last
night I mean eight of your 10 catches
were four first downs you were
responsible for more than half of the
Patriots receiving yards how's the team
feeling this morning I think we're all
feeling pretty happy and probably a
little tired you know it was an
unbelievable game it was it was great to
be a part of a resilient group of guys
and you know now after all the hard work
we get a little time to enjoy ourselves
and I think that's what we're doing
right now I know after the game you said
the first person that you wanted to talk
to was your mom what did you say to her
I just said I love you and I appreciate
her I wanted to see my family and you
know that's I wouldn't be where I'm at
without them and you know sometimes you
just got to say to let them know yeah
Julian let's just say your mom loves you
too your mustache is very much on point
I know you were talking about that
before the night
you look good this morning considering
you're probably up all night but I heard
you last night after the game saying
listen I just wanted to go out there and
do my job what were your thoughts going
into the game
my strategy particularly for me was that
I didn't want to go out there and make
any mental errors
every day every game is completely
graded throughout the whole process of
you know plus or minus on each play on
blocking assignments or pass route
conversion or anything like that and you
know I wanted to go in and have a clean
game like that I want to be able to you
know help communicate you want to hear
the personnel groups get it in out of
the huddle just a little those are
little individual goals that I had that
if you do those little things it adds up
and to make a big difference so what was
that moment like that that hug between
you and Tom Brady
uh it was awesome you know he's the
ultimate professional he's the greatest
of all time and it's been an honor to
get to play with him and you know learn
from him on not just being a football
player being a professional being a
father
he's just been you know helping me out
for 10 years now show me the ropes and
you know it's it's pretty cool to have
guys like him around Julian Edelman
congratulations on the MVP
congratulations on the Super Bowl win
great victory I appreciate it guys I
appreciate it